hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing with Game two of the
semifinals at England versus and Magnus
cross and to see who will face Hikaru
Nakamura in the finals of the Magnus
Invitational and this one is just well
it's just a great game so without
further ado let's check it out it's it's
an Italian game so a lot of crazy stuff
but we're gonna check it out
either way so e for Magnus replies wood
e5 Knight f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
c4
so the Italian game is on the board
Magnus replies with Bishop to c5 we have
the Joko piano and ding now does not go
for b4 unfortunately he goes for castles
first and Knight to f6 by Magnus so just
continuing with the Joko piano now we
have D 3 D 6 and now C 3 and Magnus
mentioned that during the fabric versus
Nakamura game that it's Nakamura who
speaks better Italian so let's see who
speaks better Italian and between ding
and Magnus with h6 rook to e1 and now
just castles Magnus also goes h3 so
taking away g4 from and from the
LightSquared Bishop and rook to e8 so
all standard stuff might be d2 going to
f1 to g3 and a6 now and that there is
one game where knife to f1 was
immediately played it's from the 2014
Croatian championship between even
charge and the anti-breakage to the
charge 1 but here we have immediate a
for biding and it is as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game so Magnus
continues Bishop to e6 offers afraid of
white barbershops ending captures and
Magnus recaptures with the rook not with
the pawn which would improve your center
but this way this way you don't ruin
your pawn structure and he's not worried
about not being able to play d5 in the
future so before now there are some 8
moves too late we have pushed back to a7
and now Queen to c2 so developing the
Queen we have Queen to d7 by Magnus and
now nice to f1 bringing the bishop over
to e3 and trading of black strong dark
square bishop and now as adding allowed
that Magnus opens up the position with
d5 we have Bishop to e3 and Bishop
captures on e3 we have Knight captures
any
3in now Knight to e7 shifting the night
over to g6 with a five biding grabbing
more space on the Queen side and now
Knights the g6 by Magnus and the g3 now
not allowing the night any jumps the g4
at the f4 or h4
and just rook to b8 so Magnus developing
all of his pieces and the King to g2
ding improves the position of his King
we have Queen to c6 now putting more
pressure on the e4 pawn and now Knight
to f5 biding and this is now a beautiful
outpost for tonight so of course Magnus
wants to eliminate it we have Knight to
e7 and here ding just captures we have
knife captures with Czech rook captures
and now c4 so putting pressure on d5 now
forcing Magnus to capture we have D
captures on e4 d captures on e4 and now
Magnus has to decide what to do here do
do keep pressuring the e4 pawn or do you
help out with the defense of the e5
point so here Magnus goes Queen back to
8 which will which will keep the e5
point sufficiently defended your you
have the D file covered and also this
makes way for the c5 a thrust which
Magnus is planning so rook 8 the d1 just
countering Carlson's rook on the default
in the now cross and goes for c5 a
temporary pawn sacrifice which if ting
accepts will will basically ruin his
pawn structure on the Queen side and
will have well a lot of weaknesses so
there isn't a better move here so the
ding just goes for it with B captures on
c5 and now you have an a5 point which
could be weak and these two CC points
which are also very weak and the rook if
if loves anything its doubled pawns so
look the c8 and nothing says okay I'm
going for the f5 square once again
Knight to h4 and here he's asking across
and are you maybe interested in further
weakened weakening your position with
the g6 but then you bring your rook to
d6 and all of a sudden black is not
feeling all that great you might have
some plans of going c5 and c6 in the
future and so on so instead we've roped
characters on c5 by Magnus and just
Knight to f5 biding so an excellent
we're for the night we have looked at
these seven and here adding trades with
rookie actress Queen captures and rook
to d1 grabbing hold of the d6 square
magnus moves the Queen Queen to c7 goes
for the c4 pawn while also pressuring
the a for EBA five pawn and now rook the
d6 biding and here Magnus has to take
take into account some ideas like maybe
knife captures on h6g captures then rope
captures Knight and so on but for the
moment just rook characters on c4 Magnus
wins back his pawn attacks dings Queen
and now it's Magnus who is up upon so
Queen to d3 biding and here we reach
this amazing moment from game 2 were
Magnus took some five minutes to dwell
on the position he has to consider a lot
of things for example you cannot capture
the pawn as the rook hang so what do you
do with this do you have to do you still
have to worry about night chapters on h6
followed by rook captures here or do you
play something else so here one
reasonable course of action would be
some like rook to c3 put the Queen back
like Queen C for trade Queens and
continue playing this game with with
pretty much a draw outcome however
Magnus after considering the position
for five minutes decided to improve the
position of his King and he played King
to h7 and we reached the position from
the thumbnail and now something is
available in the position that was not
available when the when the king was in
g8 so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find this move while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting why it works
now and why didn't work with the King
and g8 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here being just
played Ruth captures on f6 and Magnus
was like okay he captured the rook and
ding just played Quinta III and when
Magnus saw Quinta III he was disgusted
he was like he couldn't believe it he
started you know with the hands and
everything and well here we just
resigned there is nothing to do whatever
you do Queen captures on h6 followed by
Queen to g7 is checkmate even if you try
running away still Queen character
series checkmate and you cannot you
cannot prevent this
when the king was on g8 this doesn't
work because you can always shift your
king over here your king is not on h7
being down a tempo but here it just
doesn't work so after Queen to e3 Magnus
resigns and ding is now leading the
match which leaves Carlsen two games of
the rapid to get back into the match and
either win the match or or force force
blitz game mini matches so we'll see
what happens
but yeah yeah that's the game I'm sure I
hope you enjoyed it but I'm very sure
Magnus didn't I would like to thank
Kevin J Louise Charles McDonald jicama
du Lieber Ali
John Hyde and non-stop grind for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Magnus Invitational until it finishes so
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your Saturday and
do join us in the elite chess team arena
the links are in the description below
see you soon